other big story today the CDC says
Americans should begin preparing for a
likely coronavirus pandemic now the
agency says an outbreak in the u.s. is
inevitable and the disruption to
everyday life may be severe Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill where lawmakers were
briefed yesterday Nancy this this sounds
very serious is it being taken seriously
on the hill it is Tony and that CDC
warning ran counter to what the
president said which is that everyone
with coronavirus is getting better now
some lawmakers from both sides are
questioning the administration's
preparations for this virus even as the
White House argues that it's Democrats
and the media who are trying to quote
disturb the American people with fearful
rhetoric the corona virus which is very
well under control in our country even
as the White House downplayed the
disease we have tightly contained this
CDC officials warned an outbreak could
be inevitable now it's not so much a
question of if this will happen anymore
but rather more a question of exactly
when this will happen they don't have a
plan lawmakers from both sides
challenged the White House Tuesday on
its 2.5 billion dollar budget for
fighting coronavirus if you Lobo
something like this you'll pay for it
later land security yes sir
and you can't tell me if we have enough
for a spray and its plan for stockpiling
supplies have enough face masks we for
the Department of Homeland Security
we're not asking for the Department of
Homeland or you would ask him for the
American people for the for the entire
American public yes no I would say
probably not other countries have
struggled to curb the virus Italy now
reporting more than 350 cases South
Korea has reported nearly 1,300 in Iran
the Deputy Health Minister himself has
contracted the virus and the country has
the highest death toll outside of China
it seems to be getting worse not better
President Trump predicted that a vaccine
is right around the corner
health officials disagreed when you're
talking about the availability
of a vaccine even to scale it up you're
talking about a year to a year and a
half those mixed messages causing some
confusion on Capitol Hill the public's
getting a very different message from
the White House which is saying this is
all but contained well I don't can't
comment on what the White House had been
saying on this because the people who
were before the White House are not
saying that but that is exactly what the
White House is saying the HHS secretary
argued yesterday afternoon that because
the number of cases here in the US has
barely changed over the past two weeks
the virus is contained in the u.s. at
least for now
Anthony Nancy thank you